how's it going look good Oh Kevin we've
talked a couple times this year Dwayne
this is our first time meeting I know
you're very used to my colleague
Sangeeta Patel yeah there's been like a
five-year streak of she's done that
every new year so I apologize this is
what you're getting instead of be fit
beautiful singer but take a spot just
temporary don't worry Kevin last time we
talked was actually at the Just for
Laughs festival in July we're getting a
Generation Award we talked about then
like that was a huge point of view kind
of reflecting on where that was like mid
July obviously you've had this accident
how much does that moment you mean it
just shows you that you know life can
take you in so many different directions
it's up to you to understand and learn
from each of those directions and I
think I'm appreciative of all of them
you know even that moment because you
grow and you improve and your
perspective changes and one thing that
you realize that you are not in control
you don't have control and the time is
you do have here make sure it's spent
wisely and be present for those that you
should so family and friends don't take
those relationships for granted
yeah like this guy right here yeah now
in terms of there's so much pressure on
the flu it's a good it goes to the
special ends
they're gentle we gotta call it this
time this is the sign come on just go
just it's all right just go sequel give
them all this time back we're gonna do
your time okay well we quick killing I'm
gonna kill disco sequel yeah
let's pressure this time row there's so
much pressure on the first one more
pressure you think so yeah
way more pressure the summer I'm because
you know the first one the bar was low
with audiences because they didn't know
what to concede or the creative was they
were just thought oh no you're taking
something that was so beloved by us and
you're and you're extending it you're
remaking it whatever you want to call it
so but we knew then well we went into it
with incredible amount of love and
reverence for Robin Williams in the
first one we believed in our kind of
creative conceit about the body swapping
part of it so and also we came out
against Star Wars people thought we were
crazy which we were
and we kind of found our little niche in
our home and we were the unexpected hit
yeah of the year so this time around
when your first movie fortunately does
as well as it did the pressures off yeah
yeah so now the bar is high and the
expectations are high and you got to
deliver well you met that bar with your
Danny DeVito voice and the danny glover
voice were those hard things you know it
was uh it was something that that was a
true a true blessing in disguise
the opportunity to portray a legend or
legends in this film was something that
you know we jumped we jumped it and of
course by having an amazing director an
amazing cast and of course amazing
co-star like within the choices that we
made we found comfort and knowing that
we made the right decision yeah at the
time of course of filming and after the
movies completing you see the audience's
reaction it's unreal but then when you
see the Danny's and they're so happy
with what we did I mean that's the
biggest that's the biggest thank-you
compliment yeah and when we talk about
secret life of pets too we talked about
what superhero you could possibly play
but couldn't figure what you're gonna
play now this guy's gonna be black Adam
yeah can we get a role for Kevin and I
we've already discussed it we talked
about it earlier so we're we wait we're
finding that out we're figuring it out
yeah well no matter what he's not gonna
do that movie and not put me out that
would 12 so I'm ganna do we have to find
ya the part for Kevin I and the biggest
is it's awesome within the DC universe
right now or we just creates the thought
of you not put me in it I'm not saying
I'm not thinking of course
like what would the name be your name
yeah you're black and i'm black Adam
wait Adam Adam and white Adam okay yeah
congratulations this can't wait to see
that thank you thank you guys